they lived happily ever after is
basically disney's catchphrase but what
happens after a princess's happy ending
besides ariel did any other princesses
become parents
we can't assume that all princesses want
to be parents
but it's fun to picture them with a
glowing baby bump
in this video it's not just their
tummies that are getting a makeover
we're reimagining princesses with a baby
bump
new royal wardrobes and hairstyle
transformations to match their glowing
faces
i know what we have to do to set things
[Music]
right
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay our very talented artist hit the
mark with these transformations
we suddenly need pregnancy spin-offs for
all of these princesses
do you think any of these disney
characters would throw a gender reveal
party
imagine them attending one another's
baby showers
ah adorable we just know their kids
would end up being best of friends
let us know your thoughts below thanks
for watching